vintage rolex
belongs to someone i used to work with
is that the whole story
they've been out of the game a long time
but their identity still touched them
probably not
i did they still just find out about it
they'll blow their cover goodbye friend
they're just in a room who is undercover
that clint is trying to protect
there you are there you are my friend
there you are my favorite surprise
oh my god
you ain't gonna do it
you ain't gonna do it
why would you leave what
what
weren't you here to do something but
that's cool it's elena all right but why
did you leave
welcome back to new rockstars this
week's episode of hawkeye only left us
with more questions and a hankering for
snickerdoodles but what besides jack's
involvement with the tracksuits is
eleanor hiding how is clint going to
convince natasha's super spy's sister
that he's not at fault for her death in
time for the holidays but most
importantly who does that watch belong
to why is hawkeye protecting them why
can laura barton speak german what the
[ __ ]
this is inside marvel or after show for
marvel's hawkeye on disney plus we just
watched episode four i'm eric voss i'm
here with mt thoughts mt dude we got
elena it's she was rumored or like
confirmed for the show for a while we
were wondering where she was and there
she is wearing her splinter cell gear
and everything i'm so excited that's
right
yes we got elena we did not get answers
though but that's why this after show
exists so that we can just kind of reach
toward answers and throw out a bunch of
different options that most of which
probably won't be the case but we're
here all together working through this
show looking ahead to these next uh
final two episodes which i think this
series is starting to shape takes shape
like
pieces are falling into place yes yes of
course all right so partners am i right
begins with uh jack and clint from what
we can tell no discernible history
between them unless they're like
hiding something that would be weird
it's like we're just not talking to each
other but we'll just pretend like we
don't know each other that'd be weird
jack just seemed like the happiest
living his best life tv
i love this character he just seems like
he's just here for the ride he's like
i'm just here to have fun and collect
swords i love it here to make friends
but they're able to talk their way out
of eleanor's suspicion uh and then clint
snatches back that ronin sword and tells
eleanor that he will not back down but
it'll keep kate safe and eleanor's like
uh okay great i'm gonna pet it
it's like all right i'm just gonna have
to kill you now but at least uh my
daughter won't be around probably
one of the more interesting moments was
when laura alerts clint that jack
duquesne is the ceo of sloan limited and
that he is funneling money to someone
that he just called the big guy so it
still sounds like there's someone above
jack duquesne um but we will we'll see
exactly how that comes together and then
uh laura asks in german about the
avengers compound watch
what did the kids think was happening in
that moment when she started speaking
german like oh mom's on the phone with
her alt-right friends again
well kate celebrates the holidays with
clint one of the more endearing moments
of the episode you know when they've
learned how to flick coins to kill
people and almost hurt the pizza dog
we must protect this dog my favorite
christmas activity and then kate deduces
as we suspected that she would that
clint is indeed the ronin
uh meanwhile laura is tracking the watch
to a a resident so we later find out is
the home of maya lopez kate finds a list
of clint's family there
suggesting that maya may have gotten
that information from the watch somehow
or that maya and elena may be working
together uh but then
it turns into this big rooftop brawl uh
this super secret assassin with her
night vision goggles with her very super
ineffective widows bites
why did the widows bite just like
maya lopez was able to just kind of pull
it off clint was like ah my neck all
right fine they were not supposed to
paralyze you we've seen the winners
might work before or knock people on
their asses and they did not get back up
i feel like this it probably has to do
with them probably being exposed to the
widows by before um and just being used
to it they have a resistance to
electricity well like maybe not
electricity but like you know how some
people can like you know resist tasers i
just feel like if you're if you're used
to the sensation then you just know like
all right if i just pull this off then
like it'll stop i guess i don't know oh
god i i mean my thinking is that it's
it's you know avengers souped-up widow's
bite versus red room tech and the red
room tech just doesn't have the same
kind of effectiveness that an avengers
version of it does
i don't know um but we're gonna discuss
why elena was brought into this but
first who does that watch belong to
could it be that we don't know
everything about laura barton mt and i
are gonna break down the evidence give
you our theories about the possible
owner of that rolex and what
that tells us about where the mcu is
going next
couple thoughts on that first our merch
partners at the epic hero shop have a
new latest obsession shirt inspired by
hawkeye you can get it at
newrockstarsmerch.com it's a limited
edition shirt that you can get in black
white or of course purple and when you
get this shirt you'll get the added
option to write in a custom shout out
that will appear at the bottom of these
hawkeye after shows stacy says
prediction jack is pursuing eleanor
because she killed derek he wants to
push kate a way to protect her that's an
interesting thought i mean who knows
jack might actually be a a good guy in
this show oh i definitely he's this
double switcheroo
which could just be a nice guy swordsman
who is uh working for the government
maybe he's just investigating this
criminal he's going to be like mr green
and clue and all the fbi's going to come
swarming in yes let's see zachary says
uh the black widow elena in credit scene
if ekko is a former black widow could
she be the one to help clint this is
something that you theorized about mt
that uh that echo maya lopez could be a
former black widow agent
that would be the case based off what we
learned about echo in episode three
though yeah exactly like now that we
know more about echo's past we know like
where she got her you know fighting
ability i don't think she's part of the
red robe anymore she's just a girl that
just knows how to kick ass so yeah we
don't really know what was going on in
our adolescent age between being a
little kid
michael asks so what are the chances of
eleanor actually being madame mask i
think pretty good or just what the
purpose that that madam mask served in
the comics i think eleanor could serve
this purpose on the show i don't know if
they're gonna call her madame mask per
se but i i think the chances are
more likely than not i just feel like
her character is like kind of wearing a
mask um in itself because she's always
being fake i just feel like she's a fake
person at all times so like i just feel
like they might be setting it up that
way um slowly yeah um with her
personality but who knows i don't know
maybe it could happen all right mt
what's our uh leading question coming
out of this episode
well eric we gotta ask who the hawk does
the watch belong to because everyone's
talking about it it can i guess it's
like a transmitter of some sort what's
going on here it's got a transmitter in
it well i think the answer is simply
clint's wife laura barton and linda
cardellini will soon be revealed as x
shield operative code name mockingbird
goodnight everyone bye-bye
oh that would be nice i'd like to give
those
short answer options just to give people
a chance to click away
don't click away we want we need that
watch time uh well let's let's look at
what happened this episode so laura
barton is to me the most interesting
character to come out of this episode
she's revealed to be multilingual she
can speak german um and has this kind of
like pig latin that she uses it for with
clint clint just responds in english so
what was the point like the kids know
something is up when mom starts speaking
german
um and i think it's more interesting
this new element to the relationship
between her and clint that not only is
she just his partner she's not just uh
you know the mother of his kids and his
wife and his spouse that she's also like
his
espionage research partner that he tells
her to look up sloane limited and she
basically gets all the answers about it
you know she's not just the
the person in the chair she finds out
everything you could possibly know right
i don't know what google.com she's using
but let me know what that is because
that's it's got a lot of information
like they she was able to find out that
jack dukane is ahead of it she basically
turned someone in that operation uh from
her living room during the christmas
time was able to get someone in the
tracksuit organization to flip and uh
spill the beans about jack duquesne
which is a huge secret that they're
trying to keep from kate you know
mom's know how to multitask
yeah
uh and like in episode two there was
that you know way that when clint was in
the locker room she's like oh catch and
release that was an old natasha romanov
move it just seems like
now we're seeing that laura
and clint and natasha kind of were
equals as uh espionage figures and
that's why laura had this respect for
clint and natasha and never worried that
there was any kind of romantic chemistry
between them uh and the reason why
natasha respected laura and clint you
know it's just kind of a new interesting
way to see
what they were all capable of and why
they really connected with each other
she also knew a lot about this watch
like she was really worried she's more
worried than clint is about this watch
getting out like she knows that it
exists right like she knows the
inventory of avengers compound which
before the show is never something we
would have thought laura barton ever
would really care about um now she says
in german uh anything else go missing
from the compound clint goes you mean
the rolex she goes no i don't think so
wasn't it destroyed years ago and she's
like well i thought so but uh you know i
thought the same thing about your fancy
outfit and he's like i'll check the
signal from the transmitter uh and then
she later tracks it down to what is maya
lopez's outfit and then he says as we
saw in the opening clip it belongs to
someone i used to work with they've been
out of the game for a long time their
identity is still attached to that watch
and he says it could blow their cover
goodbye friend now i think the fact that
she can speak german might tell us
something in t because we know of the uh
berlin-based joint counter terrorism
center building that's where in civil
war sharon carter for shield worked
there everett ross of the cia worked
there it's kind of where a bunch of
different government agencies um not
just united states government agencies
but interpol
every spy agency in the world kind of
works together here to to restrain and
to investigate uh criminals but uh the
last time we saw this place was in
spider-man far from home where nick fury
and maria hill
were there but also that was not nick
fury in maria hill those were scrolls
so i see two possibilities if they are
building something up with laura barton
with linda carlini's character um i
think she could be
a former shield operative codename
mockingbird now this would
possibly be a retcon for bobby morse
mockingbird has been a long time
romantic uh companion to hawkeye in the
comics but i actually think they're
gonna if they do this uh make
mockingbird kind of a title like black
widow isn't like we're gonna see hawkeye
is something that can be passed down and
that maybe laura barton was the previous
generation of the mockingbird she
retired when she met clinton wanted to
start a family so that was passed down
to another mockingbird bobby morse
and then so that could explain natasha
and clint's uh friendship with her
but
more of a reach theory and i'll admit
this is a reach but you just gotta think
like if they're talking about secret
identities and they don't want it to get
out there and clint is like goodbye
friend what kind of friend could he have
that we still don't know about in the
mcu that this show seems to be setting
up well what are the big titles in 2022
we have
moon knight we have she hulk we have
miss marvel and we have secret invasion
doesn't this kind of sound like
any time you pitch scroll as the
possible answer to the question it
always sounds stupid right because
you're like really it's just a green
person until you see it until the one
division post-credits scene until the
far from home post-credits scene and
suddenly it makes sense like
i kind of i'm not saying laura barton is
herself a squirrel she could still just
be an ex-shield operative but she could
be someone who is the way nick fury has
been protecting scrolls hidden in plain
sight on earth like she could be the
link to it it kind of seems like
somewhere on this watch might be a sort
of like data chip or something like that
that
almost like the the cia asset list right
in this case it might be the scroll
asset list and all the scrolls that are
hidden uh in different government
agencies in different corners of society
and that's why it's so important that
this watch doesn't get out in the world
yeah i admit squirrels is a huge reach
and it feels stupid i don't think so man
i don't because like i i was actually
gonna guess girls myself because like
you're right i feel like you know back
in the day like if it was a year ago or
the other year previous saying skrulls
because like we know that secret
invasion was so far off we'd be like all
right it's not squirrels because we're
not it's girls yet um but like now that
secret invasion is so close like you
said i feel like it's not as much of a
reach as we become more and more um you
know closer to secret invasion so i i
think that this watch could be some type
of alien communication like maybe with
with taylor's um because taylor is you
know walking around doing his thing um
and so i wouldn't be surprised during
the course of clint's um
secret agenting um he meets um his wife
and his wife is like listen man i'm a
scroll and um this is just who i am and
but i love you and i want to be with you
and i want to be here and
so maybe clint just knows that he
married this girl and he's just cool
with it he's like you are who you are
and it's whatever and we gotta have half
squirrel half human children
and it's fine
i think
when we're you know looking ahead to
something like secret invasion we're
going to start doing this a lot looking
at everyone in the mcu on who could
actually be a scroll right absolutely i
think as in the comics they're going to
more likely reveal as oh this person was
a scroll the whole time the periphery
characters
they we might get one or two huge
characters like rhodey or something like
that
but i think everyone else is gonna yeah
it's gonna be
someone's partner it's gonna be someone
supporting character
uh you know ned or something
so people like laura barton are the kind
of suspects you want to keep your eye on
in terms of are they scrolls but i think
also like you don't have to be a scroll
in disguise to be suspicious in the way
that nick fury and maria hill were not
squirrels the whole time they just had
this relationship where they traded off
with scrolls whereas they were off on
other missions sword and talos replaced
them on earth to do other things so that
they can multitask and be in multiple
places at one time uh
i i just think as the show like secret
invasion is not a show about aliens it's
not a story about alien invaders it's a
story about espionage it's a story about
distrust of your neighbor and that's
what makes it such a cool storyline that
component of who do you trust so that
seems to be the theme
that is being set up with the questions
around this watch
there is someone who is still undercover
in a world where everyone is spies
everyone is in deep cover what kind of
deep cover is clint barton worried about
getting out there beyond that if it's
not the fact that there are millions of
scrolls hidden in uh earth society
um now uh it's just kind of hard right
now to look ahead and point to any one
answer of what this show is leading to
in the final two episodes because coming
out of episode three it was like okay
we're going to see more and more clues
for kingpin right this is going to be a
kingpin show that's going to be
the agatha all along that's going to be
the he who remains revealed late in the
show um but in addition to a couple more
clues pointing to kingpin
we're getting elena bulova and val in
this show now it seems like
val was the person who eleanor called to
put that hit on clint uh we'll talk
about
how val and elena got involved in this
uh more later this episode um but we're
also getting this hint to whatever is
going on with the owner of that watch
and i don't think it has anything to do
with either kingpin or val it seems like
it's a third
completely different vector that this
show is uh is firing an arrow out on so
it's just kind of it makes the show a
bit at this point in the game a little
unclear what the next step is since like
this whole mystery of the watch and like
who belongs to it yeah we're definitely
in a place of like it could be anyone
essentially um it could be literally any
big um marvel
gang leader um essentially i'm now at a
point where i'm not wondering what
marvel character would
appreciate a rolex watch and more
thinking of practically in the story
um what secret covert uh characters are
out there who need their secrecy
protected still that seems to be
functionally the point of this watch now
i don't understand how you hide
something on a rolex watch and why would
you put that on a rolex watch it tells
me that there's some kind of story to it
you know but like a rolex is like a
flashy piece of jewelry that might just
get stolen by any mugger on the street
why wouldn't you hide it in something
more discreet like it's like if you're
you're hiding certain video files on
your computer desktop do you put it in
cool videos folder no you put it in a
tax forms folder and you put that folder
with another folder and that folder
within another folder
amateurs right
basically where on a rolex do you hide a
chip do you just like tape it to the
bottom of the rolex and just like a
little micro sd card i i'm just thinking
what happened did they get like a pair
of tweezers to extract this every day at
4 20 the chip pops out
something like specifically for 20.
because you have to be high exactly to
think this is a good place to hide it
but no um just
something that i was just thinking about
just now uh we brought up skrulls
earlier but there is a chance that you
know laura could be a cree because in
the in the marvel universe there are
pink skinned crees that just look like
regular um just white people jude law
yeah jude law and so you know and they
did mention a cree uh splinter cell in
far from home like a secret cell right
so what if that's clint's family like
what if it's like technically like oh
that's a free cell um but you know we're
just going to leave it
what i would love in secret invasion i
don't know if they're going gonna do
that they may just make it human versus
like corrupt humans versus uh
non-corrupt scroll and then other
corrupt squirrel ruining it for
everybody i think that's gonna be the
conflict a secret invasion but man i
would love it if secret invasion is like
a shadow war between cree and skrull on
earth that no one knows what's going on
but it's kind of like um
uh
harry potter deathly hallows right you
had your wizard war going on and then
muggles were just caught in the
crossfire like
why do trees keep exploding i don't
understand
why is the wibbly wobbly collapsing i
don't understand what's happening it
makes sense because the creed scroll war
in the comics was essentially that like
they were just running amok and like
sort of just
putting their war on other people's turf
like on earth and stuff so like we could
see that yeah potentially i just don't
think the mcu has uh well i guess they
haven't really properly introduced the
scrolls objectives because they you know
it all came from captain marvel uh and
captain marvel just had so many other
narrative priorities than really
introducing the backdrop of the
intergalactic conflict arguably the mcu
hasn't been able to really focus on that
in anything i mean james gunn has done a
lot in guardians of the galaxy to
introduce the cree and their conflict
with ronan who's just like a separate
zealot uh and basically it was all on
glenn close to just explain ah crees are
[ __ ] you know
from that we got our sense of who the
cree are um but yeah i i'm curious to
see more of this uh intergalactic uh
military narrative you know i'd love to
see
you know a fellowship of the ring
prologue that just gives us a sense of
who the different military commanders
are what the past wars were
like
give me a whole series on that just give
me a whole scene why wasn't that in the
bishop files why it was bishop security
files
yeah i mean i get that's that's a huge
budget but you know what else was a huge
budget sequence aeroshim explaining the
origin of uh of earth
and eternals
and i think most marvel fans would be
like i'd rather know what happened
between the cree and the skrull than
how eresham decided to supplant
dinosaurs with
the land before time
i like that whole sequence i just think
most people kind of went over their
heads uh anyway um hey what a great time
to be alive to have all these questions
to have the mcu expanding in all these
different directions and to have no
freaking idea what's gonna happen
episode five by week marvel releases are
so good so good
it's such a cool way to experience this
because it's like heartbreaking
sometimes it's frustrating as hell to
not have all the answers but to have
like another just to be able to look
ahead six days from now and another uh
huge chunk of mcu lore is gonna be in
our lives like i much prefer that uh
plus we also get movies it's not like it
replaces movies and there's no bigger
chunk of mcu lore than the kingpin he's
a big chunk
right
the biggest chunk the biggest well we'll
get to him we're going to talk more
about elena and val and jack all these
characters but first mack weldon is one
of our sponsors this episode and we
thank them with the holidays here you
might be asking yourself
what do i wear to a non-ugly sweater
party well
mac weldon has the answer whether it's
an office party a party with family and
friends or just a holiday tv bench
session mack weldon has all the
essentials to keep you stylish and
comfortable throughout the season their
innovative daily wear system takes the
hard work out of outfit planning with
pieces designed to work together for any
occasion mack weldon's ace sweatshirts
and sweatpants and warm knit collection
are perfect for your holiday routine and
for gifts they're super comfortable for
any activity and make for a very
thoughtful gift and when i say
comfortable i mean it they feel
incredible on your body they look sharp
and mac weldon's warm knit collections
features shirts vests pajama pants and
more to keep the chill at bay on cold
days this holiday season every guy
deserves to wear unforgettable clothes
that he loves for the moments with loved
ones that he'll never forget for 20 off
your first order visit macweldon.com
marvel and enter the promo code marvel
that's macweldon.com
marvel promo code marvel for 20 off mac
weldon get it right this holiday season
also thanks to bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode guys there's nothing sexier
than confidence and bluetooth can help
give you the confidence where it counts
bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
showable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready for whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days but the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discreet package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help we've got a special
deal for our list destroyed bluetooth
free when you use our promo code inside
marvel at checkout just pay the five
dollars in shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code inside marvel to receive your
first month free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and we thank bluetube for
sponsoring the show uh also we want to
thank aura frames for sponsoring this
episode all your loved ones really want
for the holidays is to see you if
schedules or distance get in the way of
getting together make their wish come
true with an aura smart frame
thoughtfully crafted and easy to set up
an aura frame keeps you close to the
people who matter most making it easy to
share photos and now video too from
anywhere around the world using the aura
app no wonder oprah added it to her
favorite things for a third year in 2021
it's easy to pre-load photos and you can
even reach out to other family members
to contribute aunt mary is always taking
her photos and he can finally put them
to good use beautifully wrapped in ready
to gift any aura frame can be
personalized with cherished memories and
delivered right to their door for an
easy last minute gift that will warm
their heart and help you stay connected
all year long last year aura frames
completely sold out so don't wait visit
auraframes.com and get gifting now
that's a-u-r-a-frames.com
use code marvel to take thirty dollars
off aura's best-selling digital picture
frames and thank you to shudder for
sponsoring this episode scary movies are
always in season and with shutter you
can stream great thrillers horror and
suspense for 5.99 a month shutter is a
netflix of horror and has the largest
fastest growing curated selection of
thrilling and dangerous entertainment
stream on all your favorite devices they
have a lot of exclusive content
including some really great documentary
series like cursed films and behind the
monsters and a horror themed drag
competition series and they've got a ton
of new rockstar staff favorites
including train to busan i love that
film so so good they also have halloween
day of the dead all your favorite horror
movies and they've got some new stuff
the classics and foreign films you name
it everything and he won't run out of
interesting things to watch so get
started streaming the best horror
thriller in supernatural content
shutter's expertly curated collection
includes must-see titles like vicious
fun the mortuary collection and pg
psycho gore man plus all the best horror
documentaries and the hit creep show tv
series from executive producer greg
nicotero over the walking dead so to try
shutter for free for 30 days go to
shutter.com and use the promo code
marvel that's
s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com and promo code marvel
for 30 days free all right mt why the
hawk was elena hired to kill clint
barton could eleanor
also be working with
val i think there's a good chance there
i think that um eleanor and val could be
in links together and i think this is a
wild theory this is a bit of a rogue
theory but i've been saying it for a
while but i really just think the
intelligentsia is in play if for those
who don't know the intel who the
intelliancia is they're this group of
like super smart supervillains in marvel
that uh assemble to like sort of like
manipulate things in the shadows and
like you know uh try to change the world
in their with their smart way and they
were teased in age of ultron with a claw
there's a little piece of paper that's
like in claw work at the intelligencia
um and so i think that we're finally
seeing who the intelligence is in the
mcu and um they're just trying to get
rid of clint for his involvement as
ronin and like you know getting involved
with all these um criminal organizations
and ruining their plans that they were
um carefully uh
planning in the shadows um so this is
probably an extension of that i feel and
like eleanor's powerful friends are
these intelligentsia people um of just
evil smart people um which is like your
modoc i think egghead eventually val
um
zemo maybe down the line he's super
smart so they might recruit him val
seemed pretty impressed with zemo by the
end of [ __ ] winter soldier um so i
think that this is like the secret group
in the shadows working here but what do
you think i mean other than modoc that
group sounds lame like i know there's
other people i just i'm blanking
star coming back
but
i don't want there to be like a specter
of the marvel universe with just like
the lamest uh villains that they can get
to come back like if the intelligentsia
comes in i think doom might be too dude
right if it's doom if it's modoc yeah
now i'm interested but like verify amiga
playing a version of madame mask
like fine i but i think what this tells
us is i don't think you're you're wrong
in that there is some kind of um there's
a text chain between bad actors
at the very least and i think what this
tells us is that the reason that val
gave to elena to target clint that oh
wouldn't you like a shot at the person
responsible for your sister's death that
may be the reason that val told yelena
to motivate her but i don't think that
is uh val's reason to want clint barton
dead i think she may have her own
reasons and now it asks it forces us to
ask when did that black widow post
credit scene take place it deliberately
showed it in colder weather and i am
wondering if that scene could have taken
place during episode four of hawkeye and
then so val then made the decision based
off of uh eleanor's request
to put the hit out on clint barton and
turn to her deadliest assassin
deadliest in quotes because she has a
widow's bite that is shitty that does
not work
at all more like a widow's nibble really
not really a bite
but um yeah i i think that it tells us
something about val i think we already
kind of suspected that val had some
corrupt intentions the fact that she
wants to work with john walker uh the
fact that she seems so shady in a way
that she approaches
bro do you think we'll see john walker
in this i don't i think we'll figure out
more about what john walker is a part of
like i think by the end of this show we
may get some hints that uh we may hear
the word thunderbolts or something like
that you know i hope so i don't know
what word they're going to use but
there's going to be something to where
some vague
noun common noun is used and then on
inside marvel will be like she's talking
about the dark avengers so she's talking
about thunderbolts so i we might get
some answers yeah but i think the
implication of uh kate bishop finding
that list of names in maya lopez's
apartment it suggests that elena is
working with maya or maybe has like uh
made a deal with her or something like
that they have something in common but
remember elena knows that clint barton
is the ronin based off of that photo
that val showed her so maya may already
know that information now too and that's
why maya has that list elena just told
her she showed her that photo look the
hood is down but this is the ronin
costume and so now maya is like all
right i'm gonna find every possible way
i can get at clint barton find all of
his vulnerabilities that was interesting
they had the ages of the first two kids
but not the age of nate uh yeah which i
just thought was interesting like she's
like maybe that data was pre um you know
prenate's
birth and like they they knew about his
first two kids but they didn't know
about uh nathaniel that's really do you
think that information was derived from
the watch or given to maya from elena
did elena write that list or maya i have
to assume maya wrote that list right
because um i think maya wrote the list
but she got the information from
somebody else who may have known clint
before
um his son his last son's birth um so
just someone that he that he just from
his past that him maybe him and laura
knew before um nathaniel's birth from
their past they strike me as a
group of people who don't have a lot of
family friends yeah but i i just i just
have this weird feeling that like
clint and his wife were spies together
and they probably have another spy
friend that they worked with at some
point like at least one person natasha
maybe and he's like giving up this
spilling the beans because he doesn't
like them anymore he's like yeah here's
clint's family
i don't know i i think if they got it
from anyone they just got it from me
elena i think that's the easiest
approach there but i i'm just um not
really sure if if maya already knows
that clint is the ronin it's just
interesting the way this show is like
withholding secrets from other
characters but then just seems to let
that information just fizzle out as
opposed to like making that a big
revelation that's that's the best thing
in storytelling when chara when the
audience knows more than certain
characters do um so that way you can use
that as a wedge point of conflict so
that's why i wasn't i was surprised i'll
say when laura barton just kind of
spilled someone behind the scenes off
screen uh told her that jack ducane is
the ceo of sloan limited like that's
information that you can use to like
twist things but maybe they just decided
like the audience at this point fully
knows that jack dukane is bad news
but that actually makes me want to ask
you mt next question is jack duquesne
full of jack [ __ ] because what's going
on with this guy
what's going on with this guy why did he
want the ronin sword so badly uh did he
actually kill armand and
could he actually just be a nice guy red
herring i think he i think ultimately he
is still going to be uh a bad guy he's
just not gonna be the ultimate bad guy
i don't think so i think that jack du
kane is literally going to be
um a marvel hero this is what they're
setting up he's basically the elena of
this show um she's like hey i'm here um
you're gonna see me do some cool stuff
and then uh i'm just gonna leave with my
swords by the end of this and like i'll
i'll pop up somewhere else i just think
that he's just like this really adorable
guy and like we see that kate's starting
to like him more as a person um as she
gets to know him eventually she's gonna
find out that her mom's a terrible
person and so um she's gonna you know at
the end of this she's probably gonna
hate her mom and sort of like jack more
uh because like jax is he's just a
really eccentric guy just like all right
i just want to have fun and collect
swords so i don't think that he's an
evil person i think that he's probably
tied to things that he doesn't fully
understand because he's just a sword guy
um well i got to be honest with you i
don't think jack duquesne has been a
particularly well-written character on
this show um we're getting real we're
spilling the tea now i like tony dalton
overall i think the writing on the show
has actually been pretty good
but i think
right now they're clearly setting
something up but if they're trying to
hide something about jack ducan they're
doing a very poor job hiding it but
they're trying to make him a more fun
you know knives out wear his villainy on
his sleeves mystery character he's not
that entertaining either tony dalton is
fascinating to watch in shows like
better call saul that guy knows how to
do so much with so little dialogue but
they invented this goofy sub game for
him where he mispronounces certain
aphorisms which feels like
vaguely problematic right yeah i'm not
gonna get into that but it's like
just problematic from a character
development standpoint like it just
makes them into like
a pickles cartoon comic strip character
um
and if i i i look at him the way um
sharon carter was written in falcon
winter soldier and we had all these
different theories everyone has like a
different take on jack dukane like oh is
he actually a spy working for the
government who is gonna arrest eleanor
at the end of this is he actually a bad
guy is he actually is he uncle and i
think ultimately
we have to learn our lessons from the
falcon of the winter soldier and the
clues that the show is giving us let's
just for now interpret them the way the
show has given it to us that he clearly
is meant to be suspected but like they
have said explicitly that he works for a
big guy there is still someone at the
top of all this who is not jack duquesne
i don't think jack dugan was uh was
another ronin identity i liked that
theory last week after this week i don't
think that's the case i i don't want to
go to i think the answer the reason why
everyone has their own pocket theory for
jack ducane
is because he is not being well written
on this show
and it's he's kind of a mess of a
character um i might change my tune next
week but these first four episodes he
has been all over the place and i'm
gonna make something clear with all
mystery shows you are supposed to be
withheld information you're not supposed
to know everything about a character
about their intentions that's what makes
mysteries fun but right now there is a
distinction between mystery and
confusion and i think there's straight
up confusion about what what we're
supposed to feel when jack is on screen
i thought it was so weird how kate
suddenly uh flipped her opinion on jack
just based off of this creepy thing of
them dancing in a room while he's
singing like you are willing to overlook
everything that you know and suspect
about this guy and just because your mom
laughs that's enough for you and then in
the next scene clint says oh actually no
he is the ceo of sloan limited this
guy's corrupt
it seems even like haley steinfeld is
confused how to interpret that
information
the way it's delivered so i just think
this character's all over the map i'm
not crazy about the way the character's
been written and i'm not gonna get lured
into crazy rabbit hole fan theories
about jack duquesne i'm just gonna i am
on the opposite train here i love jack i
think that jack they're setting him up
to be this really adorable character um
but yeah at this point you know he is
sort of confusing in terms of his um
intentions like what's really going on
with jack and how he's
being written but i think that by the
end of this series hopefully anyway
there'll be a payoff to like as to why
um
he was presented that way but like i i
honestly feel like jack has a lot of
potential in the mcu
i i hope you're right i'll say that
i hope you're right
biggest friend capsule and for all of
you uh watching right now who may be
like why is eric being too hard on the
show look this is just how we interpret
shows we're allowed to have like
a frustration moment to moment
throughout the show i'm not gonna write
off this whole show i'm loving this
whole show right now i'm just saying
certain characters can frustrate me at
certain times and i think it is right on
us to hold them to a higher standard of
scrutiny um because that's how we
appreciate when these shows are good
anyway i wanted to ask you i think a
very interesting moment into this
episode was uh when kate decided to
not shoot elena just based off of elena
shaking her head
what do you think that was about
well uh i think the real answer is uh
kate just knew elena was about that life
and uh she just didn't
uh want to test that uh no um i think
this all has to do with kate not really
being prepared for the hero life because
you know obviously you know she did all
that you know crazy stuff with the track
suits and all that stuff um but when
it's
she she had the choice to kill elena
like headshot or try anyway and she was
just like i don't know if i can and like
this is sort of what clint was sort of
getting at um in this episode it's like
this life is not for you and like
obviously he's motivated by eleanor's
comments to leave her out of it um but i
just think that she's going to see the
the more gruesome parts of being a hero
um the the more ronin-y type parts that
you know clint wants her to stay away
from and just be a kid um so i think
that could be kate's motivations there
but how about you what do you think i
think she was in that moment trying to
learn from clint when he said the most
important shot he ever took was the one
he didn't
he she saw her black widow potential
partner and friend in that moment she
saw like a connection there was that
moment where florence pugh did such a
good job i think just
non-verbally saying
this isn't worth it there's something
more here she kind of represented a
mystery box to kate bishop and she
wanted to learn more before she just
killed this person
there clearly is an important story here
um
and i think she wanted to hear her out
and give her a chance clint said there
was just something in natasha that he
saw she wants out of this and i think
i think kate saw the same thing in elena
in that moment i thought it was a pretty
beautiful moment where kate kind of
became the hawkeye that she thinks clint
wants her to be
oh yeah no that's that's a spot on
analysis at that moment um because like
you just a perfect reference to what he
said before because um kate's gonna be
the new hawkeye and elena's gonna be the
new black widow that's sort of what
they're setting up here it's like i'm
gonna not take the shot too because
we're the legacy characters we're taking
over and like we gotta do the same thing
symbolically all right as we look ahead
to episode five we have been told that
episode five is going to be a game
changer
i think we need to be on kingpin watch
are we for sure going to see vince
d'onofrio wilson fisk show up in hawkeye
next episode mt nope uh because it's
going to be the aerospace engineer i
cannot wait to see the voice again and
they're running the whole show
it's gonna be amazing to see this
amazing review it's gonna be the
aerospace engineer and paul bettany uh
work
at paul penny's white vision just
working together
what a weird moment in one division that
was they said like i know an aerospace
engineer and it was just like her uh
air force friend in the world right like
the cinematography when she teased it
was like oh this is going to be a big
deal but then it was like all right just
some girl like all right cool thanks for
the van i guess uh but no um i think
that vincent d'onofrio's kingpin is for
sure
going to at least be teased or
referenced he's gonna probably show up
at the end like it's me it's cakeben
i'll see you in episode six so yeah if
he's not in this i'd be very shocked i
agree i think there was some confusion
this episode where clint was talking to
laura and she was like so um yeah he's
running sloan limited he's the head of
it and he goes jack ceo so he's
laundering money for the big guy and i
think the he of that sentence was
confusing is he talking about laura's
source or is he talking about jack
laundry money for a big guy over him i
think the latter is the case i think
jack is the one who's laundering money
for some other big guy and later clint
sells kazi you know what maya's boss
wants you know what he's done to get it
he doesn't like this attention that's
for sure i think he just would use the
term jack
if like he was trying to get i think
clearly there's some kind of unnamed
boss as of yeah yeah uh and i think
that's who's gonna get revealed um i
mean it's very clearly vincent
d'onofrio's chuckle last episode uh the
fact that he was wearing this fine suit
the fact that his footsteps were heavy i
don't think it's that crazy to expect to
see kingpin show up in hawkeye uh but if
you didn't know any of these clues
uh i still would say watching this
episode just as a casual viewer
you wouldn't sense that this is going to
be a show where kingpin shows up in like
you have to kind of know what the comics
are about
like we didn't see the track suits other
than kazi this episode uh and i guess
other than maya but like the show kind
of this episode took a step away from
the organized crime element of it you
learned more about sloane limited but
there was like it was more about clint
and uh and kate's christmas relationship
oh yeah i mean that's why the episode
was called partners am i right
but i think the reason this may have
felt like a bit of a filler episode to
some viewers is i think they are kind of
timing this out and pacing it so that
the week where we find out whoever uncle
is is gonna be the week where spider-man
no way home drops and we just learned
that you know charlie cox is confirmed
to be daredevil at some point in the mcu
but i think that tells us we might see a
charlie cox matt murdock and spider-man
no way home
and if he is in the universe potentially
everyone from the defender's side of the
universe can now be in the main mcu and
the other big player other than you know
arguably jessica jones john bernthal is
uh as a punisher frank castle luke cage
really dinofreo is kingpin is the next
most recognizable character after
charlie cox's daredevil uh or at least
the most recognizable villain and uh
turk barrett obviously yeah
so
of course how could i okay um so yeah i
think that's what we can expect there
was even talk that we might see a new no
way home trailer on uh the 15th which
would be the day before the release in
the u.s the day of the release in the uk
which i think would be so weird why
would he why would we see a no way home
trailer that day unless it is going to
reveal some information that comes out
on the hawkeye episode 5 that comes out
on the 15th
i i'm probably thinking too hard about
that no like i don't think that you're
thinking too hard about this at all
because like it makes sense the timing
is a little bit too suspicious um yeah
for because we do have these daredevil
elements in hawkeye and we have those
daredevil elements rumored for
spider-man it would be weird and like
very
um just silly of marvel to not take
advantage of these two things and like
line them up perfectly so i think you're
exactly right of the money there i think
we're gonna get a huge daredevil week
next week with um you know hawkeye and
spiderman and like that diner scene um
that was rumored it's probably daredevil
like i think you said it in the past
episode like you uh brought that up oh
my god
you're probably right uh so yeah i think
the as as we learned more and more so
far we're probably gonna see daredevil
talking spider-man in that diner well we
will see that is it for this episode of
inside marvel we're going to be back
next week with our reaction to the world
breaking episode 5.
i just i want to let everyone know i'm
still really really loving hawkeye i
have gripes about little components of
it but who knows how i'll feel next week
and after episode six but this is just
how we are working through the show we
don't always get every uh part of the
journey as we're on the journey but at
the end of the journey we can look back
and truly assess it so uh don't get on
me for being hard on this show we should
all be hard on everything that we watch
and have hearts on for everything we
watch
the bluetooth
what the hell am i saying anyway uh well
don't forget to check out our many great
merch options at new york
sourcesmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow mt at mastertainment follow new
rockstars subscribe to inside marvel
wherever you get your podcast thank you
for watching we're gonna close with our
favorite moment this episode
you